bonjour baptiste gatouillat merci d'être
avec nous ce soir sur rtl france alors
en pleine période de confinement le
ministre de l'agriculture didier
guillaume appelle les français sans
activité à aider les agriculteurs
n'est ce pas contradictoire m'écouter
pour soi déjà à tous alors c'est pas
forcément contradictoires ce que l'on
sait que dans la boue en agriculture et
rend d'autant plus dans l'est dans les
produits frais les maraîchages fruits et
légumes
on a besoin de vraiment d'avoir de la
main d'oeuvre sur les exploitations
or justement récolter les produits qui
sont périssables et qui arrivent à
maturité pour pouvoir après les
vendanges ford en distribution soit sur
les marchés qui ont autorisé sont
devenus comment va se passer exactement
l'organisation de ce travail comment
va-t-on pouvoir vous vous contacter et
quelles vont être les conditions de
travail pour ces pour ces volontaires
sur la prise de quotas qui a ça peut
être un local directement des
producteurs que les que nos concitoyens
connaissent ou alors se rapprocher de
plates formes qui sont en train de se
mettre en place sera permettent type le
weezy charme des petites start-up qui se
met en place
et puis pourquoi pas se rapprocher aussi
des syndicats agricoles et les chambres
d'agriculture qui seront en capacité de
réorienter la même ardeur réussi avec
avec pôle emploi c'est aussi une grande
chance comme menacés n'avoir pas
d'acteurs sur le territoire on nous
permettent de mettre en relation ceux
qui voudraient travailler et puis ceux
qui ont besoin de main d'oeuvre et
mettre en place aussi des contrats pour
ceux qui le font de façon bénévole de
pouvoir le faire sous forme de bénévolat
mais pouvoir aussi les protéger en cas
d'accident de travail qui peut arriver
et retrouvez toutes les formes qu'ils
vont bien pour aussi sécurisé à la fois
les personnes qui vont venir nous aider
sur les exploitations mais aussi
l'employeur des manoeuvres alors didier
guillaume le ministre de l'agriculture
rappelle lé grand distributeur aussi à
faire
apple alors solidarité injustement et
faire appel à des producteurs français
j'imagine que c'est quelque chose qui
peut vous soulager
alors oui c'est déjà quelque chose que
nous on souhaitait depuis très longtemps
le le manger français du made in france
ça c'est quelque chose que l'on porte
depuis toujours chez les jeunes
agriculteurs
il a en période de guerre contre le
contrôle coronavirus on a encore plus
besoin de ce patriotisme alimentaire et
si voilà ça aidera aussi peut-être les
gens à changer un petit peu habitudes
alimentaires c'est dommage d'en arriver
pendant des sanitaires
mais oui on a besoin aussi des gms pour
que l fasse la promotion du manger
français et que avec les producteurs
locaux et réorganiser le si
l'approvisionnement on est capable en
france de fournir l'alimentation nos
concitoyens français en quantité et
surtout en qualité on l'a vu dans un
sujet tout à l'heure la fermeture des
marchés ouverts qui va poser beaucoup de
problèmes à au producteur est ce que
c'est quelque chose qui vous inquiète
puisque cette fermeture est à durée
indéterminée pour l'instant
ah oui ça nous inquiète parce que voilà
il ya une possibilité vraiment d'avoir
beaucoup de marchés de fermer en
revanche marqué un point qui est assez
important ce mini c'est que les mères
avec les préfets pourront réouvrir ou
une manière l'ouverture des marchés en
plein air et ça avance et que les mères
c'est souvent les plus à même de pouvoir
nous faire respecter les règles et puis
le site voir juger si tel ou tel marché
peut se permettre d'être ouvert et si je
prends le cas souvent dans des petits
marchés de deux petites villes ou de
campagne en règle générale vous prenez
connaissent des producteurs et les gens
ont l'habitude et sont prêts à respecter
ces gestes barrières c'est quelque chose
d'important
il faut aussi quand même respecter ces
gestes barrières comme ils devaient être
respectés en grande surface comme dans
tout autre secteur
il faut que j'en ai marché tout soit
fabriqué forme que des maraîchers
puisque souvent servent d
des consommateurs si on respecte les
règles il n'y a aucun souci il faut que
les marchés puissent ouvrir et souvent
c'est aussi un lien dernière sociale et
de territoires parce que ce soit il faut
faire plusieurs dizaines de kilomètres
pour aller après s'est offert ses
comptes en grande surface donc le ferait
en local reste l'alternative aussi pour
ne pas trop diffusé le le virus
baptistin gatouillat racontez nous un
peu comment ça se passe exactement sur
place actuellement peut-être chez vous à
dire et saint pierre
est ce que cette phase de solidarité
s'est déjà mis en place est ce que on
vous êtes déjà est-ce que vous avez déjà
reçu des appels de personnes volontaires
alors nous on n'est pas dans un bouge
pas dans un secteur il ya beaucoup dans
de demandeurs de maraîchage mais la
survie certains secteurs mais ça
commence
ça commence à arriver puisqu'ils ne sont
qu'une solidarité qui se fait entre
agriculteurs pour justement aider des
fois dans les travaux dans les champs où
la main d'oeuvre
c'est compliqué ou pour pouvoir
continuer à collecter par exemple le
lait dans les fermes c'est tout simple
il ya des fois des laiteries des petites
laiteries qui sont obligés de de fermer
parce que ils ont quelques uns de leurs
salariés qui sont qui sont malades et
donc du coup et bien d'autres
entreprises viennent prendre le relais
pour que les agriculteurs ne soit pas
obligé de jeter le lait ou tout à
l'égout mais bien de pouvoir collecter
les faire des yaourts du lait du lambris
du fromage avec donc voilà cette
solidarité s'organise et puis petit à
petit voilà les agriculteurs ouvrent
leurs portes notamment aux transporteurs
pour que des foyers puissent se
restaurer puisse prendre une douche
ferme c'est des choses qui se mettent en
place et des choses qu'on me faisait
peut-être habituellement de temps en
temps mais là on le le se faire plus
grande échelle
donc ça va s'organiser puis dans les
secteurs plus de maraîchage où il ya
déjà de grandes actions de solidarité
qui se met en place
alors des fois souvent c'est de la
famille qui vient qui vient aider parce
que c'est aussi peut-être plus facile
mais on a vraiment besoin de toutes les
bonnes volontés des personnes qui
voudront bien nous aider à pouvoir faire
perdurer notre notre activité parce que
si il ya des pertes sèches
exploitation voilà c'est aussi un pan de
l'économie qui sera encore fragilisée
suite à cette épidémie donc la
solidarité dans le monde paysan on la
connaît et on l'a faite au livre
merci beaucoup baptiste gatouillat
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir et je
rappelle que vous êtes vice président
des jeunes agriculteurs merci beaucoup